hello everyone welcome to another
episode of unlocking lily so I believe
that this world would be a better place
if we all just embrace who we truly are
and when after what we truly wanted
which is what inspired me to do just
that to start a business to help people
create an extraordinary life based on
their terms Evan is currently an
investor in my business he's also
helping me grow my business around my
coaching and speaking and inviting all
of you guys to join me on my startup
journey so far on my journey you guys
have seen me grow both as a coach and as
a speaker you saw me talk on my fear and
filming in public for the very first
time you followed me through the mentor
lounge at the sage summit and all of you
cheered me on when I went on that TEDx
stage and I shared my story and on the
coaching side I revealed to all of you
how I became a coach in the first place
by saying yes to Evan suggestion to
realizing my true calling and being a
coach since then I have coached hundreds
of people from around the world across
six continents which is pretty amazing
and mind-boggling at the same time and
what really brings me a lot of joy and
happiness is working with my clients
seeing them grow seeing them bring their
dreams into reality and it makes me so
incredibly happy that I get to be with
them every step of the way and it made
me realized that I wanted to reach even
more people because I believe that this
world would be a much better place if we
all stepped into our true purpose and
did exactly what we were meant to do and
at the same time I realized that
coaching can be very expensive for a lot
of people and I wanted to find a way to
make it accessible and make it
affordable for everybody so guys I have
some exciting news I'm about to launch
my very first online trading program
where I'm going to be coaching a small
group of people who's going to have
direct access to
and my coaching services at a very
affordable rate in addition to God I
wanted to create a community a community
of people who are encouraging loving and
supportive of each other one of the
things that I loved about being a dance
instructor at Toronto dance salsa is
seeing the connections amongst my
students formed they walk in being
complete strangers and they walk away
building these lifelong friendships and
sometimes love relationships and most
importantly they're building their tribe
of people that they feel like they could
belong with so that's what I wanted to
bring in my coaching practice as well I
love my one-on-one time with my coaching
clients at the same time I also want
them to build connections with each
other I want to build a community where
people can be encouraging can be
supportive people who are like-minded
and most importantly keep each other
accountable for the things that they're
supposed to do in life and lastly this
is a program that I wanted to launch a
year from now but you guys know Evan if
there's something that you want to do in
the far future he will do everything he
can to bring it to the immediate present
and I was really nervous in doing this
in the next couple of months but you
know what I feel ready I feel like I
have worked with enough people and I've
seen enough common patterns to put that
into a course to help even more people
but I'm also looking for some feedback
from you guys as well to make this
course even better so what am I going to
be covering in this course you ask I
have divided it into three sections so
then section number one is going to be
all about discovering your inner self
this is a time that we let go of who we
should be and step into who we truly are
we're going to walk through your one
word process we're gonna walk through
the Credo and we're going to form goals
and actions
line was what we truly value in life
section number two is possibly the most
important section of the three which is
about breaking down your limiting
beliefs and breaking down the walls of
self-doubt because once you're
discovered what it is how you stand for
and who you are and you're about to make
some bold moves those are years of
living beliefs are going to pull you
back to where you used to be this is
where we're going to identify what your
limiting beliefs are discover what the
root cause of them are and replace all
of those negative thinking patterns with
positive actions and section number
three which is my personal favorite is a
contribution and the impact that you
want to have in this world I realize
that I've gone through a lot in my life
and I have done a lot to build myself
back up I have achieved a lot of success
and really the next step for me is to
really live a life of service to others
which is why I do all of this in the
first place and I think that's the
important thing here when we discover
something that is beautiful something
that profoundly changes our life we want
to share it we want to share with our
friends we want to share with the rest
of the world so here I'm going to
identify what is the positive impact
that you want to have in this world some
people want to have an amazing family
have amazing children that is going to
benefit the world be an amazing husband
being an amazing wife being an amazing
friend being an amazing worker and some
people want to lead a world-changing
mission in leading the next generation
to a greater purpose and there are a lot
of people somewhere in between and
everyone's impact is going to be unique
and this is where we need to identify
what is the impact that you really want
to leave in this world and what is a
legacy that you want to leave behind you
so that's what I'm going to be covering
in my course if you guys have any
feedback at all please leave in the
comments below as well as in the next
edition of unlocking
I will be releasing all the details to
this course and if you want to know the
launch date feel free to email me at
Lily at Evan Carmichael dot-com and it's
it's going to be a small group it's only
gonna be nine people and I hope to hear
from you guys very very soon
and have a special shadow for hey Z's
day he's used a thank you so much for
writing the comment in my last video
your support and love means a lot to me
and I hope you're having an amazing day
thank you guys so much for watching and
most importantly being on this journey
with me I'm learning a lot growing a lot
and changing a lot and it brings me so
much comfort and knowing that you guys
are there with me every step of the way
so thank you guys so much again and I'll
see you guys very very soon bye bye
raise your standard Apple at the core
its core value is that we believe that
people your passion and not one drop of
my self-worth depends on your acceptance
of me I don't ever give up I'd have to
be dead or completely incapacitated hey
believe nation if you want to see my
all-time favorite top ten rows of
success I have a very special secret
video for you these are the individual
clips that I have personally learned the
most from and applied to my life and my
business check the link in description
for details